it's been a week of devastating and
indiscriminate attacks on ukrainian
civilians this time it was the southern
region of odessa
another apartment block
more innocent civilians asleep in their
beds
those caught in the impact stood little
chance
two campsites were also hit in the same
attack
children among the dead a pregnant woman
among the injured
this is not a single strike it's not a
coincidence as russia's media says daily
it's a direct russian missile strike
it's russian terror let's be honest
against our cities our villages our
people both adults and children
the kremlin continues to say russia does
not target civilians but these attacks
continue to happen
another residential area was hit in kiev
in the early hours of sunday morning
then a crowded shopping center in the
central city of kremenchuk just a day
later
it's understood the same anti-ship
missiles fired on the shopping center
were also fired on odessa
weapons that are inaccurate on ground
targets
inappropriate for urban areas
this latest attack could have been
retaliatory after russia lost control of
the strategically important snake island
the day before
the rocky outpost oversees odessa's
shipping lanes ukraine's biggest black
sea port where food cargo has been under
blockade for months
far from easing the threat to nearby
odessa retaking snake island perhaps
made it a target
it will be for war crime investigators
to determine if these attacks are
deliberate
but they are clearly reckless with
little regard for civilian life
sally lockwood sky news keeve